well for the next few weeks you can help
a local dog or cat find their forever
home happening now is the animal
foundation's clear the shelters event
madison kimbrough live with how many
adoptions it has seen thus far hi
madison
[Music]
yes hello it's really a great event that
happens every single year and there are
so many animals out there that need to
get adopted to find their forever homes
so so far the amount of animals that
have been adopted out have been about 23
and they estimate to complete 40
adoptions by the end of the day the
animal foundation is waiving adoption
fees for all adult dogs and cats to make
it easier to adopt that includes dogs
and cats six months or older last year
more than 700 pets were adopted
throughout the entire event and that's
what's so great about clear the shelters
it isn't just a day or a week event it
lasts till september 19th it's an
opportunity for older animals to be seen
and find homes because too often they
get overlooked for the kittens and the
puppies the event which started this
morning already had a line out the door
before they even opened
we had around 50 people who were waiting
when we first opened so we do recommend
getting here early but there's also
until the 19th of september to come down
and meet your new best friend
if you are interested the shelter
suggests you check the website to view
the animals available and then once you
have found your match that is when it's
time to head on down here and start the
process again clear the shelters event
last till september 19th and at last
check so far in total there are about
225 dogs and cats available as of now so
come on out here reporting live from the
animal foundation madison kimbrough 8
news now